the battle for speaker turning into an
even bigger dumpster fire for
Republicans Jim Jordan officially out
after losing the third vote this week
and things are getting heated behind
closed doors Kevin McCarthy reportedly
scolding Matt Gates during a conference
meeting telling him to sit your bleep
down I was at the mic I was speaking and
Matt Gates tried to interrupt and I told
him to sit down and he sat down I told
him to sit down I I think the entire
conference screamed well you know he he
loses his temper sometime maybe it's the
Irish in him
[Music]
I think I wonder what bleep was probably
ass you know Jesse uh let's get to the
heart of the matter here why a duel no
why haven't I been nominated I put my
hat in the ring like a month ago and I
seem like the natural the Natural Choice
I don't think you do well in DC really
why that no I don't think you'd get
along with people yeah I'm an outsider
yeah you're a little too much of an
outsid I'm America's bad boy you really
dream
that America does not want you as it's
bad boy we have others so I this is what
my sources are saying and I don't know
if this is true Jesse who are they fine
I'll just make it up the the
appropriators in the house don't like
this guy because he doesn't want to
spend a lot of money and he's not one of
these spendaholics so they knifed him in
his back behind closed doors and other
people wanted to stay over the weekend
and the guy with the bow tie the short
guy yeah Pro or whatever they call him
the mry The Substitute Teacher he's he's
like no we're taking the week off and
then they're all jazzed to go on their
foreign delegation trips on Friday and
so they don't even care who they have
they just want to go abroad yeah go
ahead the closest person to getting the
gavl is the minority leader Hakeem Jeff
a Democrat I mean I I'm con Nancy Pelosi
must be like cheering and high-fiving
all of them the Republicans have shown
themselves to be a bunch of Fools and I
am embarrassed for them I really am they
blew it up you know those eight blew it
up and they blew it up with no
resolution and then you go from McCarthy
to scalise to Jordan I who's next I have
I have my sources tell me these two
names who Arrington and Hearn honestly I
don't know who any of them are but those
are what they're saying are the next big
guys at this point why would you even
want to do it like who's going to
volunteer I volunteer besides Donald
wants it I could do this show from
DC yeah let's move it no that we don't
you can live at br's house you know what
if it's for the country Brett's house oh
you're willing to give it up for the
country I'll mooving to Brett's house
it's up for sale there'll be a wing in
there for you yes exactly Jessica the
secret ballot part of this is the most
amusing thing so in front of everybody
195 196 Republicans voted for Jim Jordan
and then when they were allowed to
actually say what they think only 8 six
voted for him 112 against makes me think
obviously what would have happened with
that vote to convict in the impeachments
of Donald Trump but guess what people
don't like being bullied kenb these the
voicemail that was left on the wife of a
congressman a republican congressman's
phone Jake Tapper played it yesterday
abhorrent really geez yeah oh wow you
have your people like slamming the Jews
out there a voicemail doesn't seem that
bad yeah thing I mean aren't they big
boys you know don't you see what they do
in Parliament they're about ready to
knock hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else